you were featured in a Superman comic
yeah Superman a tight
that's groups that's a high honor well
you did a spit thing on that woody I
know I met Superman did you meet
Superman no I didn't mean right so then
so what are you you know I hate to the
planetarium yeah because he wanted he
heard that we have special tools there
this is in DC Comics mm-hmm
they we had special tools to see faraway
places and want to see the destruction
not a real Superman what is the who play
Superman more real to you than the comic
book character on which all else is
based I think not okay you're incredible
logic has defeated us that's nice that's
a nice toy showed him the destruction of
his planet yeah which took 27 years to
get here which meant he got here like on
a wormhole I had to tell I told the DC
Comics people that and I found a star
that would fit his home planet Ares and
they named that yes yes yeah it's an
actual star in the night sky that I hand
it to them and it's in the constellation
Corvis The Crow and only then did I
learn they said oh that's good I said
why they said because Smallville's
mascot is the crow and so this is a star
in the constellation the crow in the
southern hemisphere which is about the
right distance for him to come to my
place and look through our devices and
see the destruction of his home planet
it was a sad moment we dropped his head
down and who may need it like a hug cuz
it's not often he's he he knew
intellectually that his home place was
destroyed but now he saw it with the
light finally catching up with his life
here on earth so I I think you should
leave
[Laughter]
you want a picture of me with Superman
that's good